it takes courage to win people don't
talk about people that don't win
if you win they're going to talk about
you you wasted too much of your life
trying to change
other people's mind about you don't tell
me that you want something if you're not
willing to throw
what you got at it hello believe nation
my name is evan carmichael my one word
is believe and i believe that
entrepreneurs will solve
all of the world's major problems so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from pastor and thought
leader bishop td
jakes and my take on his top 10 rules
for success vol
2. rule number 10 is my personal
favorite and i'd love to know which one
you guys like the best and as always as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
put quotes around it so other people can
be inspired
you might win a prize as well and also
when you write it down it's much more
likely to stick
for yourself as well enjoy
do you have the courage to act
outwardly on what you see inwardly
[Applause]
or will you die a dreamer will you die
on the verge and on the edge and on in
the land of kutta
water and sugar
[Applause]
this wrong hand rules the ruse
do you have the courage i'm going to
drop something on you
it takes courage to be successful
[Applause]
it is far easier not to be successful
[Applause]
misery will always have company
success breeds contempt
if you don't want to make waves be
mediocre
be normal and fit in and if you're more
concerned about people than you
are god then neutralize everything he
put in you
just fit in with everybody else dress
like them
walk like them act like them eat like
them go where they go
think like they think do what they do
and once you neutralize your uniqueness
you don't need courage it takes courage
to be different
it takes courage to go where you've
never gone before
for some of you it took courage to come
to this conference
it takes courage to get you outside of
the bar it takes courage to be
successful
it takes courage to win people don't
talk about people that don't win
if you win they're going to talk about
you do you have the courage
to stand there though the storms keep
raising
and the people get to talking and you
stand there and say
i've come too far to turn around
that's your girlfriend and say do you
have the courage
i'm gonna i'm gonna say something to you
it takes courage to be exceptional
it takes courage to be wise it takes
courage to be rich it takes courage to
be educated
it takes courage to be knowledgeable
because the moment you do it
you don't talk like you oh you didn't
god forgot where you came from look at
you
it takes courage and i'm just wondering
in this weak watered-down mediocre
society that we live in today
in this reality tv world we live in
today
i'm wondering if there's anybody left
that's got the courage
to say after all i've been through and
all my ancestors have been through
and all my parents have been through i
didn't come through all of that
just to fit in with normalcy i have the
courage
to go after my dream to be anxious is to
have anxiety about something that hadn't
even happened yet
some of you are so worried about the
threat of trouble
you're not in trouble it's just that
trouble has threatened you
and the threat of what might happen what
could happen
it's wearing you now half of the things
that you thought were going to happen
never did happen but if you allow those
thoughts to dwell in your mind
it will succeed at robbing you of your
peace
robbing you of your joy robbing you of
your life just because you
fought yourself into a nervous breakdown
you thought yourself into depression
you thought yourself into defeatism the
mind is the battleground
the fight is in your mind so i want to
challenge you to waste
no more effort wrestling with other
people
oh i lost you i lost you you were doing
real good i lost you
your destiny your future is not
predicated
on the decision of someone else
you wasted too much of your life trying
to change other people's mind about you
it doesn't matter what they think about
you
god is not gonna bless you by their
opinion god is gonna bless you by how
you see
yourself
touch somebody and say i believe i'm
coming out
i don't know how long it's going to take
i don't know what i'm going to have to
go through i don't know what i'm going
to lose along the way but i
still believe that i'm coming out i've
been broke i've been busted and
disgusted
but i still believe that i'm coming out
i'm locked up in prison
they say i'll never get out but i
the people who became the most
successful in our society
are people who broke the rules you know
there was no
presidents for 24-hour news cycles until
ted turner did it
there's so many people who got out of
the box uh look at apple and the birth
of the whole notion of apple or nike
i talk about in the book of the birthing
of that corporation how they did
something with the tennis shoe that had
never been done before
if you only base your decisions on
empirical data
you can only repeat what somebody else
already did if you follow your instincts
and your own god-given creativity
we could go where we have not been
before be strong
and very courageous be strong
and very courageous be strong
and be of good courage be strong
and possess the land because god knows
that for what you're going to do it is
not by
our strength
[Applause]
you understand you understand she helped
me preach this thing this morning girl
it's inner strength so my fourth point
is you got to have inner strength for
this fight it's not your outer strength
it's not by might nor by power but by my
spirit saith the lord so you got to have
that inner
that inner that inner that cut strength
and belly strength that devil defined
come hell high water strength that
rolled me out in front of them and i'll
preach from a chair strip
that tenacity to take a licking and keep
on taking that
inner strength that well i can't do as i
would i'm going to do as i can
but i'm not going to stop doing to the
best of my ability
i'm going to stretch your
be
heart
strong strong strong
strong i am afraid that too many times
we have put so much focus on teaching
you to be good
seed that we haven't taught you
the power of good soil
and so when we come to soil issues
the seed ignores the soil
we flick the channel that has nothing to
do with me
we close our eyes because we have been
taught to be
good seed but we have not been taught to
pay attention
to soil and yet the bible is clear jesus
says
the sword went forth sowing seed
and some fell by the wayside some fell
amongst rocks some fell among stories
the whole text is about environment
[Applause]
look at you and look at your
environment
have you been positioned to flourish
positioning has a lot to do with
flourishing
to be in an environment in a family that
supports you my sister and i were
talking the other day
i was telling her what an amazing person
she is that all of our lives together
and and all the things that god did in
my life not once in
all of the years that i've known her and
she was there when mama had me
have i ever known her to be jealous of
me
not once not ever she has always been my
cheerleader and my greatest fan
and she said how can i be jealous of you
you're my brother i said a lot of people
have siblings that hate them that are
jealous of them that hope they choke and
some of my development has to be that
god planted me
in an environment of people
that supported me my brother my sister
my mother my father they all
supported me you can have good seed
but if you've been in bad soil
people who hated you environments that
denied you
education that underserved you
communities that limited you
mentalities that poisoned you
until you hear what i'm saying if if
your
soil wasn't right it doesn't mean that
you're not right
but if your soil wasn't right it's going
to affect how you root
and how you grow and you might grow a
little bit
the bible says you can grow for a while
but then the
gorge will choke you out or the rocks
will not have enough soil
for your roots to grow are you blaming
god
for something you ought to be blaming
the soil for
you cannot take a peach
seed and plant it in a teaspoon of dirt
and expect it to grow though the
teaspoon of the dirt is the same size as
the peach seed
it will not grow the seed will only grow
when it is planted in something bigger
than itself
and i want to know where are you playing
it this morning
are you planted in something bigger than
you
or have you always been planted in
teacups
surrounded by little dirt little
resources
small-minded people narrow limited
places
that never let you stretch to reach your
capacity
sometimes you got to go where the corn
is
you call comfort in your book a cage
comfort in the cage
we used to be pioneers that's how the
country was settled and and we start
pioneering new things we
we stay where it's comfortable we play
where it's safe we
we don't really get out into the wild of
the possibilities we stay in the
confined
cage of that that is uh tangible and
touchable
nine to five and that's it but we need
more creativity and
we need to follow our instincts now
without that you you may make some money
but you won't find fulfillment
always go to something
bigger than yourself
i'm wondering if you've been defeated
because you have been giving yourself
holy to something that was too small to
hold you
[Applause]
have you trust yourself into a glass of
water
have you leaped off the diving board
into a cereal bowl person
are you not guilty of immersing yourself
into things that were too small to hold
your vision
[Applause]
oh my god this is so good i'm gonna get
the cd myself
[Applause]
jesus sent him to throw himself into
something
that was bigger than his condition
and he had to go to get to it he had to
get out of his comfort zone
my problem is so many times you've
thrown
big ideas as small people
you've given big commitment to cereal
bowl people
and you're trying to get your site back
from a source
that's too small to support
what you're willing to put in is your
investment bigger than the bank
you should see the way you're looking at
me is your is the reason you keep
being disappointed by people is that you
have wholly thrown yourself
into something that was too small
jesus sends him to something that is
bigger than himself
so he can wash
his eye are you trying to take a bath
in a bowl david was a shepherd boy
out there trying to take care of the
sheep
and didn't have nothing to work with and
a lion
came against him and and he took a rag
and said this is the kind of stuff you
make to fight
back with when you don't have nothing to
fight with
have you ever gotten to a fight and you
didn't have nothing to fight with
but you took what you had and you said
such as i have
i'm not gonna let you take my stuff my
job my
opportunity my life my family's legacy
you're after my family's legacy i'm not
gonna let you do it
and even though i don't have nothing
fancy to fight with
like a degree or like a million dollars
or like a bunch of friends but i'm gonna
roll up what i
got and i'm gonna throw it at you
[Applause]
you kill the lion
kill the bear
with this rag
this rag whole dirty rag had thrown
rocks
and everything that ever come against
you
if you live long enough a lot of stuff
will come against you
and you gotta you gotta
throw what you got at it
[Applause]
you can't throw what you wish you had
you can't throw what your neighbor had
you got to throw what you got at it
that's what separates the men from the
boys because you you got to throw what
you got at it if you don't
don't tell me that you want something if
you're not willing to throw
what you got at it since we're talking
about business we're talking about money
you can't be tribal and be a global
thinker at the same time
the reason money is called currency is
that it needs to be able to flow
and the issue is do you have a vision
that flows beyond people
who look like you dress like you and
vote like you and if you're gonna do
business you can't do segregated
business and do it well
if you've got a product that you believe
in or message that you believe in
or a movie that you believe in or
whatever it is you want to reach the
broadest amount of people and most
people think probably
all of their relationships their
contacts their associates are tribal
and you block the ability to succeed
when you block the ability to
communicate beyond your tribe
life demands that you pick up the pace
if you don't pick up the pace
you're going to be left behind i'm
amazed at the people
that like the flexibility to pick up the
pace
they just get in a rut i stroll down
here
and i'm gonna stroll back i'm gonna
stroll
over here i'm gonna stroll over there
one of the most amazing things about the
disaster
at malaysia is that when it happened
everybody had to pick up the pace
all the news media had to pick up the
pace they were booking night flights and
flying over here and flying over there
somebody had to work overtime won't be
home for three days
typing in the middle of the night
research going on because when something
happens
everybody got to pick up the page that's
why i
can't deal with people who cannot pick
up the pace don't be strolling when i
got a
i need 911 who can pick up the pace
slap your name and say pick up the pace
something is about to happen pick up the
pace something's about to happen
pick up the pace something is about to
happen pick up the pace something is
about to happen
pick up the pace something is about to
happen pick up the pace something's
about to happen
i came to tell the young people pick up
the place pick up the page
pick up the page something is about to
happen
the danger of low expectations
i would rather aim for the stars and not
hit them
than to not aim at all i would rather
go after it and not get it than not go
after it at all
i'd rather try and fail than not try
at all i don't want to live with the
idea
wonder what would have happened had i
done more
with my life i'm gonna go for it come
hell
or have water i'm going after
my destiny touch your neighbor and say
run
you gotta run after your destiny you
can't stroll
after your destiny you can't walk after
your destiny
you gotta run somebody holler wrong
you gotta run you gotta run
you gotta run you can't just wake up in
the morning let me see what's gonna
happen today
i don't know what i'm gonna do i don't
know what i'm gonna wear
i don't know what i'm gonna cook i don't
know where i'm gonna go
i just woke up oh you should stay in the
bed
give the day to somebody who's gonna run
after their destiny
give the day to somebody who has a plan
who has a strategy
because success is never an accident and
if you don't want it
get out of my way because there are some
people
who want to do something with their life
who will
run
[Music]
thank you guys so much for watching i
made this video because christopher
asked me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you are going to
profile next check out the link in the
description and you can go
and cast your vote i'd also love to know
which clip resonated the most with you
what lesson are you going to take from
this video and immediately apply
to your life or to your business somehow
leave it down in the comments below i'm
really curious to find out what you have
to say
i also want to give a quick shout out to
cyrus webb cyrus thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book your one
word
and making that video on your youtube
channel i really really really
appreciate it bro
and i hope you enjoy the read your one
word by evan carmichael
thank you guys so much for watching i
believe in you i hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever
your one word is much love i'll see you
[Music]
soon
have you franchised what works in your
life
that's what the second step is so many
people become fruitful and they say this
is working and i've done this and i've
accomplished this
but i'm not fulfilled at it anymore and
i'm frustrated i wonder why
i feel the way i do the reason you do
because you haven't taken the second
step
once it works in a microcosm in a
controlled environment
in this city or that neighborhood or
this place
you want to then multiply that which is
fruitful you want to terminate
that which is not i talk you know i talk
you'd be surprised i talk a lot when i'm
on stage i'm quiet when i'm at home
i'm very quiet when i'm at home i tend
to be a very quiet person
you got to balance you can't just be
rattling all the time
it drives me crazy when people talk too
much
it drives me crazy when they just go on
and on and on and on because
see i pay attention
and which you're not going anywhere with
this it drives me crazy
what one of the strengths of preaching
is outline because the outline gives the
listener something to follow
that has structure when you're all over
the place everything you're saying may
be true
but because your message has no focus it
becomes hard to follow
it's hard to follow somebody who doesn't
have focus
where are we going with this what is the
point of what are you talking about
get to the point what is this about and
for a while you'll listen
because you're trying to see if it has
structure and when you figure out that
they're just talking and it has no
relevance
you go deaf